The End Ich will auch vor Gericht nichts wissen eigentlich mehr jetzt. Aber jetzt ist der Punkt gekommen, wo du möglichst wenig wissen sollst einfach. Ich wusste von nichts, dann freigesprochen. Kann man das zum Thema machen oder ist es weil es laufende Ermittlungen ist? Es ist jetzt halt die Frage, wann ist der Punkt, wo man nicht mehr drüber reden darf. Ja, können wir ja gleich in der Folge besprechen. Gut, dann geht's los. Ja, dann drei, zwei, eins, Stefan, bitte. Ja, aber das kann nicht so wichtig sein. Komm, Stefan, geh ran, nee, da muss ich... Ich mach mal der Dings, man merkt ja, dass man weggedrückt wird, ne? Ja. Wenn zweimal klingelt, wurdest du weggedrückt. Zweimal klingeln ist kein natürlicher Klingelausgang. Ja? Kein Handy sagt nach zweimal klingeln, na gut, der ist offensichtlich nicht da, ich schalte mal die Mailbox an. Nein,, viermal oder sowas, wenn du zweimal klingeln hörst und dann bist du weg, wurdest du weggedrückt. Was ist, wenn du dreimal klingeln lässt und dann wegdrückst? Bei dreimal bin ich mir nicht sicher. Ja, aber der kann ja nicht rückgängig machen und dann das Klingeln zurücknehmen. Warum solltest du dreimal klingeln lassen und dann kannst du auch zu Ende klingeln lassen? Hä, natürlich, erst mal Panik, Schweißausbruch, überlegen, wer ist das, was soll das? Weil ich bin den Leuten in meinem Telefonbuch ja primär nach Funktion, nicht nach Namen. Das heißt, da kommt dann irgendwie dann immer irgendwie Typ, den ich da und da getroffen habe, auf dem und dem, mit dem, mit blauen Haaren und dann nochmal, wer war das nochmal genau, was blaue Haare, nachdenken, nachdenken, nachdenken, dann wegdrücken, dann schon noch drei. Nee, genau, kann sein, was ich auch nur sagen wollte, euch an die Hand geben musste, ist, bei zweimal werdet ihr sicher weggedrückt. Bei allen anderen Sachen kann ich nicht garantieren, was genau passiert ist am anderen Ende der Leitung, weil das weiß nur Gott. Aber das ist auch neu. Oder Vishnu, je nachdem. Nee, bei zweimal klingeln und dann weg bin ich mir sicher, dass ihr weggedrückt wurdet. Okay. Grosser Tipp für euch, auf den ich, muss ich echt stolz sagen, selber gekommen bin und den habe ich ein paar Leuten erzählt und die sind wirklich geflasht gewesen. Wenn eine Nummer euch anruft, eine unbekannte Nummer, jeder kennt das Problem, man weiss nicht genau, wer es ist, will man zurückrufen oder ist es was Wichtiges, ist es nicht Wichtiges, hat man diese Nummer vergessen, eine einzuspeichern oder war es nie nötig, eine frem person ruft an was ich mache ist ich speichere diese person ab diese unbekannte nummer als vorname unbekannt nachname datum deswegen habe ich in meinem handy bestimmt fünfzig unbekannte nummern die heißen alle unbekannt 17.10 zum beispiel dann schaue ich bei whatsapp nach dem prof dem Anzeigenamen. Wow. Und tatsächlich sieht man dann bei den meisten Fällen, dass es ist, woher die kommen. So eine Anime-Figur. Ja, genau. Fuck, was ist das? So eine Grinsende mit so Sternenaugen. Ja, genau, mit so einem Peace-Zeichen. Oh, da muss jemand auch, nein, mit der war ich in einer Parallelklasse. Scheiße, die AOK wieder. Das kam noch mal. Kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Das ist Nina aus der Parallelklasse
damals. Da sieht man so ein Foto, ein Schulfoto,
wo so eine kleine Animefigur auch vorne sitzt.
Aber sie sieht auch damals so aus
wie in der achten Klasse. Einfach hat sich nicht geändert.
Ja, nee, sieht genau so aus.
Nee, aber tatsächlich, wenn mich
unbekannte Nummer anruft, gehe ich im Leben
nicht ran. Natürlich nicht.
Ja, aber ich finde Leute so spannend, die dann so rangehen, so, oh, unbekannte Nummer, gehe ich mal ran. Ich denke mir, auf welchem Planeten lebst du eigentlich? Leben wie komplett andere Leben, fallen bei dir Dinge nach oben, wenn du sie loslässt. Was ist los bei dir? Einfach komplett anders, das ist einfach völlig unvorstellbar. Das denken die Menschen aber auch über dich, und dann gehen sie rückwärts, verlassen sie ihren Raum. Das stimmt, und dann verhaften sie einen Polizisten. Einfach ganz normaler Alltag. Und schneiden dem Frisur die Haare. Das sind halt die Dinge, die ihnen passieren. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist echt interessant. Aber es gibt viele Menschen, die auch Überraschungen mögen oder so. Situationen, wo sie nicht Herr der Lage sind. Seid ihr bescheuert? Ja. Wie kann man nicht in Kontrolle sein wollen gut finden? Ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt. Aber ich glaube, ich bin einmal Opfer einer Überraschungsparty geworden und ich bin nach Hause gekommen und habe vor meiner, also eigentlich, das ist ein bisschen umständlicher, weil ich eigentlich wollte eine Party machen und es war so unangenehm, ich konnte die Nacht davor nicht schlafen, es war furchtbar und schrecklich und ich dachte so im Garten Lagerfeuer machen und ich war mir nicht sicher, wird das Wetter schlecht, wird das Wetter gut und dann wachst du so auf und es ist ein kleines Nieselwetter und du weißt, okay, in zwölf Stunden ist die Party, lieber absagen, lieber direkt absagen, ich habe heißt, denen wurde die Party abgesagt, sie sind aber trotzdem gekommen, um mich zu überraschen. Also das klappt ja hinten und vorne nicht. Aber du hast denen abgesagt. Ich habe allen abgesagt, ja. Und alle haben entschieden, nein. Ja, genau, alle haben sich dann hinter meinem Rücken zusammengetan und gesagt, der hat zwar abgesagt, aber wir kommen trotzdem. Was zum Teufel. Also komplett der Bullshit. Aber die haben sich zu dir nach Hause eingeladen.
Nach Hause, ja.
Waren auch in meinem Zimmer, während ich nicht da war.
Also wirklich das Schlimmste, was es gibt für mich.
Das macht man aber auch nicht.
Und dann haben die dann zumindest für Verpflegung gesorgt und gute Laune.
Ich bin angekommen, habe die Fahrräder meiner Freundin gesehen, umgedreht und wieder gefahren.
Nein, das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Ja, ich bin wieder gefahren, ich bin nicht nach Hause gekommen.
Bitte das?
Ich wollte die da aushungern lassen einfach, weil ich mir dachte, das kannst du jetzt nicht machen.
Und dann wurden irgendwann 18 Leichen gefunden von Jugendlichen.
Da sieht man auch so, wenn du diese Überraschungsparty machst und du wartest hinter der Couch, wie lange wartet man, bevor man sagt, wie lange würde es dauern?
Wie lange würde es dauern?
Also wir packen jetzt wieder die Gelanden ein und den Kuchen, tun wir wieder zurück in die Plastikbox und fahren wieder nach Hause.
Nichts Trauriges als Gelanden einzurollen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ja, ja, wir haben den Krebs besiegt, lieber abnehmen.
Ja, oder diese Luftschlangen, die am Boden dann überliegen, die man so auspustet, nach Silvester häufig, diese Geste, dieses wütend, diesen Müllsack, diesen großen Müllsack, den man auch nur hat an so komischen Occasions, wo man dann plötzlich sehr viel reinpackt, immer so Party-Utensilien um die, pur hat die Hüte, wütend reinpackt. Oder das Geburtstagskind, das selber dann noch die ganzen fucking Luftschlagen aufsammeln muss. Ja, und das Konfetti. Kein Konfetti. Auf gar keinen Fall Konfetti. Leute, Silvester steht vor der Tür, Leute, macht keinen Unfug, feiert verantwortungsvoll, Und zwar indem ihr einfach mal einen schönen Futurama-Marathon macht, irgendwie fangt um 20 Uhr an und hört um drei Uhr nachts auf und geht ins Bett und es war's.
Und seid schön leise, damit die Nachbarn nicht hört.
Schön leise immer sein, auch für die Haustiere, also jeder kennt die Haustiere, jetzt ist ja dieses eine Video viral gegangen von dieser Baby-Eule, da war Gewitter und die Baby-Eule hatte Angst und so und da hatte ich mir auch Leute, pssst, pssst, einfach mal ein bisschen ruhiger sein. Wie, das Gewitter jetzt oder was? Allgemein. Allgemein, einfach mal ein bisschen, einfach mal ein bisschen piano. Du hast ja gerade das Eulen-Beispiel angesprochen. Wo hat das denn jetzt gerade? Das Gewitter ist ja natürlich, wir müssen ja auch eine Baby-Eule nicht eher sich daran gewöhnen, weil die Welt da draußen ist vielleicht für Baby-Eulen manchmal zu krass. Wobei ich muss sagen, ich habe noch mal eine kleine Beschwerde an die Evolution. Grundsätzlich gute Ideen dabei. Viele gute Ideen. Augen, viel Quatsch auch dabei. Augen, top, kann man zumachen. Mund, lecker, kann man zumachen. Ohren, kann man nicht zumachen. Warum nicht? Naja, warum? Aber es macht keinen Sinn, Ohren zuzumachen. Doch, ich bin fürs Ohrenlied. Ohrenlied 2020. Du brauchst doch etwas, was aufbleibt. Du kannst doch nicht komplett in den Shutdown-Modus gehen. Du musst doch so einen Stand-by-Modus haben. Ach nein. Doch, klar. Quatsch, heute kommt doch kein Säbelzahn-Löwe mehr zu dir. Wie willst du denn so einen Wecker? Wie soll ein Wecker sonst funktionieren? Ja, dann kannst du ja die Ohrenlieder auflassen, wenn du weisst, du willst geweckt werden. Stell dir mal vor, wie geil das wäre. Ja, gut, Kino ist ein schlechtes Beispiel, da hört man nichts mehr. Aber es ist doch anstrengend, was auflassen zu müssen. Ist doch auch nicht anstrengend, deinen Mund aufzumachen. Du kannst doch sagen, ich schlafe jetzt mit offenem Mund, wenn ich geweckt werden will. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass du das entscheiden kannst, ob du mit offenem Mund aufwachst. Du verlierst ja die Kontrolle über die Nacht, über deinen Körper. Naja, aber der Körper sagt... Fühlst du dich an irgendeinem Punkt, als Herr über deinen Körper? Aber das ist so, wie wenn man irgendwo hinkommt, man wird zum Chef gerufen und die Tür ist offen. Dann lässt man beim Rausgehen die Tür auch wieder offen. Man geht so, wie wie man gekommen ist und so ist es in der Nacht auch, wenn du mit offenem Mund einschläfst, dann sagt der Körper auch, okay, klar, im Laufe der Nacht machst du zu und was auch immer, aber am Ende der Nacht wird dann wieder aufgemacht. Kein Ohrenlied, weißt du, wie ich dagegen, kein Ohrenlied, Nasenlied? Nasenlied, das finde ich super spannend. Das finde ich richtig gut.
Wie oft würde ich gerne das Nasenlied zumachen und dann muss der Mund aber offen bleiben.
Machst du dir manchmal aktiv mit Zeigefinger und Daumen die Nase zu? Nee, muss man auch nicht machen, weil du kannst das ja mit der Zunge hinten korrigieren, weißt du?
Du kannst mit der Zunge deine Nase schliessen.
Ja, du kannst den Nasengang, das hängt ja alles zusammen im Rachen-Mund-Raum.
Da kannst du ja aktiv dich entscheiden, nicht riechen zu wollen mit der Zunge.
Wie bescheuert, natürlich kannst du das machen, oder?
Was? Klar.
Das ist zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben.
Du kannst die Nase...
Ich müsste diesen Blick sehen, wo Stefan seine Nase schließt.
Angestrengt.
Naja, was man machen kann,
macht alles zu. Was man machen kann, ist halt aufhören zu atmen,
weil in dem Moment, in dem du nicht mehr atmest, riechst du ja auch nicht mehr.
Das mache ich auch gerade.
Oh Gott, Stefan
verrenkt seinen Mundraum,
seinen Rachen.
Nee, ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht.
Ist wie damals,
da habe ich auch schon mal versucht, gleichzeitig einzuatmen durch die Nase und auszuatmen mit dem Mund. Dass es so ein Kreislauf ist. Weil es wurde immer mal gesagt, Didgeridoo-Menschen, die können gleichzeitig mit der Nase einatmen und mit dem Mund ausatmen. Deswegen können sie einen nie endenden Ton mit dem Didgeridoo herausposaunen. Pardon? Heraus Didgeridoo. Richtig. So, und da dachte ich immer, okay, spannend. Erst mal sehr laut. Was macht dann deren Lunge die ganze Zeit? Weil ist die dann so halb aufgepustet oder gar nicht? Ja, das war halt links, rechts, links, rechts. Das ist ja Quatsch, weil die nehmen einfach nur die Zeit zum Überbrücken, um in der Nase wieder einzuatmen, ist die Zeit, wo sie in dem Mund Luft gesammelt haben und da rauspusten.
Das heisst, die machen den Kapseln den Au ab, also den Mund von der Nase, Raum. In dem Moment pustest du die übergebliebene Luft in deinem vollgepusteten Mund aus und die Zeit nutzt du, um mit der Nase da einzuatmen. Ah, verstehe, dann kommen die dicken Wangen. Dann kommen die dicken Wangen ins Spiel, ja. Und das macht, glaube ich, schon Sinn. Aber die atmen nie gleichzeitig ein und aus. Das habe ich für mich selber jetzt gelöst. Nee, ist auch besser so. Leute, lasst das. Lasst das einfach. Ja, ja. Lasst das. Seitdem ich gehört habe, dass man seine Zunge verschlucken kann, bin ich auch ein anderer Mensch, ehrlich gesagt. Das war der Moment, wo ich dachte, ja gut, jetzt kann alles passieren, jetzt lege ich mich in die stabile Seitenlage erstmal und hoffe, dass mir jemand trinken und essen bringt und mich, keine Ahnung, so künstlich ernährt mit so einer Infusion. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich noch überleben soll. Nee, kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen. Es gibt ja so Videos von so Fussballspielen, wo die irgendwie ineinander laufen und dann verschlucken die Zunge und dann der gegnerische Spieler hilft ihm und ju, er hat das Leben gerettet, super Sport. Und da dachte ich mir auch so, ich werde nie wieder Sport machen, nie, nie wieder. Und meistens ist dann, genau, meistens ist dann so der Titel des Videos Superfaire Geste vom Gegner. Ja. Ja, wo man sich überdenkt, worum glaubt der G-Zweil-Fussballspiel?
Es geht nicht darum, den Gegner umzubringen oder irgendwie um jeden Preis zu besiegen.
Es geht darum, mehr Tore zu schießen.
Aber wenn der Gegner jetzt eine Zunge verschluckt, einen Herzinfarkt hat und man ihn wiederbelebt, ist das keine faire Geste.
Das ist einfach das Menschlichste, was man tun kann.
Und vielleicht ist es ja auch das schlechteste Spiel der Mannschaft. Da will man ja, dass der auf dem Platz bleibt.
Und dann rettet man den, damit er bleibt.
Und... Unfaire Geste, das ist einfach das Menschlichste, was man tun kann. Ja, und vielleicht ist es ja auch das schlechteste Spiel der Mannschaft, da will man ja, dass der auf dem Platz bleibt. Und dann rettet man den, damit er bleibt und nicht ausgewechselt wird. Unfaire Geste, man wiederbelebt den schlechtesten Gegner. Und wie unfair. Sportgericht entscheidet Geldstrafe für den Verein. Aber kriegt man dann auch ein Bonustor obendrauf, oder? Da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Aber noch zum Thema Nase ist, ich fand auch immer so, also irgendwie, ich gehe nicht mehr Schwimmen, Swimmingpools, so, ich habe das Gefühl, das ist ein Thema in meinem Leben, das einfach abgeschlossen ist als Kind, ständig Freibad, Sommerbad, See und so, mittlerweile gar nicht mehr. Und da auch irgendwie gab es dann so ein paar Kinder, die, wenn sie ins Wasser gesprungen sind, nicht die Nase zugehalten haben. Ja, aber diese Klammern haben viele auch. Und ich habe mir nie die Mühe gemacht, auch nur mal nachzufragen, warum so nie gemacht, nie, aber einfach so hingenommen. So, okay, manche machen das halt so. Du bist ja vom Her bei deiner Nase. Du kannst ja entscheiden, auszupusten. Wenn du kein Wasser drin haben willst, ist das, glaube ich, sehr einfach. So einfach.
Aber weiss man eigentlich, wo das hingeht, was man durch die Nase hochzieht?
Ja, Rachenraum.
Also dieses klassische Rotz hochziehen und es landet dann im Gehirn oder so?
Nee, das ist ja hinten im Rachenraum, da kannst du es schlucken, das kannst du ja runterschlucken, du kannst den Rotz hochziehen und runterschlucken.
Wo ich mir dachte, es ist ja immer noch in meinem Körper, Aber tatsächlich werden die Bakterien getötet vom Magen. Die Magensäure, die ist ja schon auch clever. Wir werden richtig schlau, langsam. Wir werden richtig schlau, habe ich das Gefühl. Wir haben nicht mehr so viele Wissenseinbahnstrassen auf jeden Fall. Ja, also die letzten Folgen haben wir viel im Dunkeln getappt, aber ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind jetzt auf der anderen Seite angekommen und können mal so ein bisschen aufklären. Ja, bis wir merken, dass wir auch nur in einem komischen, weirden Nirvana stehen, dann wieder zurück durch den dunklen Tunnel nach draußen kriechen. Ich habe heute etwas Phänomenales gesehen, was mir wirklich den Tag verschönert hat. Ich bin hier mit dem Car-to-go-Mietwagen hergefahren, schöner Mercedes natürlich, klar, nehme ich mit. Und dann, was ich noch nie gesehen habe, weil da ist ja der wirklich erbärmlichste Scheiss teilweise in so einem Car-to-go-Wagen. Ich habe eine Avocado gefunden mal in einem Mietwagen, warum auch immer. Ganze, richtige. Eine komplette Avocado im Seitenfach, einfach schön Avocado im Seitenfach. Avocado im Handschuhfach. Nee, im Seitenfach. Im Avocado-Fach. Seitlich-Fach, nee, nee, schön im Früchtefach. Neben dem Avocado-Fach. Ja, neben. Und heute habe ich gesehen, schön, man kennt ja manchmal so diese Stoffwürfel, die man sich so um den Spiegel hängt, die dann so runterdengeln. Habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Und genau in diesem Stil eine Chromfelge, eine kleine Chromfelge um den Spiegel gehängt im Car2go Auto. Ja, also da hat jemand. Du musst nicht Car2go Auto sagen. Da hat jemand gesagt heute fahr ich car to go schön mercedes hole ich mir hat dann seine miniatur aufhängefelge mitgenommen die über den spiegel gehängt dann eine gute zeit gehabt und dann sie aber hängen lassen was ich gerne machen würde, ist, den Wagen des Car2Go in klein da aufzuhängen. In klein. Und zwar mit dem Menschen drin, der drin sitzt. Und zwar müsste man dann, das ist für diesen Prank, müsste man jemanden doll beobachten die ganze Zeit, seine Car2Go-Route checken, dann wissen, okay, der fährt morgens neun Uhr zur Arbeit. Ja, und man arbeitet mit der App zusammen, du kannst ja sehen, welches Auto er bucht. Genau. Und bevor er einsteigt, kannst du noch schnell so ein 3D gedrucktes Auto rein. Richtig, du müsstest wissen, wohin er, du müsstest am besten einen Car-to-Go am Abend vor seiner Wohnung parken. Ja. So, dann müsstest du das Car-to-Go anfertigen lassen, 3D-Drucker, kleines Mini-Car-to-Go-Plastastik und da drin offensichtlich die Jacke, die er trägt, das Face. Das war schwer, am selben Tag dann noch. Du musst ihn beobachten, man zieht ja jetzt im Herbst oft den gleichen Wintermantel an. Grosses Risiko. Und vielleicht musst du ein paar Autos vorbereiten, so dass seine Hauptoutfits raussuchen, vorbereiten und dann das jeweils, oh, das Kaum räumt, zack.
Wie, aber da musst du sehr schnell sein.
Wieso jemanden respektieren? Ja, dann kannst du ja noch so ein paar Komparsen haben, die ihn aufhalten, irgendwie so eine große Glasscheibe über den Weg oder so.
Er ist ein sehr gelaborierter Prank, aber dann alles nur für den Moment, für den kurzen, sieht ein bisschen so aus wie ich.
Für den Moment, wo die Kameras aufnehmen, dass er einfach nicht hinschaut, weil er stressig in die Arbeit muss. Ja. Das wäre ja auch mal eine schöne Prankshow, eine Prankshow, in der alle Pranks schief gehen. Ja. Es gibt ja auch so internationale Prankshows, die ja offensichtlich eingekauft sind, die nicht in Deutschland produziert wurden, aber es gibt bestimmt so Preise für jeden Prank, so jeder Prank kostet Geld. Und da gibt es bestimmt auch Pranks, die richtig scheiße gelaufen sind, die man so für einen Zehner dann kaufen kann. Die man noch nirgendwo gesehen hat auch, weil die immer schief gelaufen sind. Einfach mal so die billigsten Pranks kaufen und einfach die schlechtesten Pranks Deutschlands, das überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Ja genau, da würde man so das ironisch gucken, das Format da. Und dann vor allem in seiner Arbeitsstelle, wo er dann ankommt mit seinem Car-to-Go, stehen dann alle bereit und ah, geprankt, geprankt. Was? Wie? Da ist ein kleiner, der Kopf sieht ein bisschen so aus wie du. Okay, ich muss dringend zur Arbeit jetzt los. Nee, wir haben frei, extra. Und dann auch mal so die Zeitlupenaufnahme, wie er reagiert auf den Prank. dann so in Zeitlupen so ein völlig Stirnrunzeln. Ja, genau so ein verwirrtes auf sich selbst zeigen. Aber es bleibt trotzdem One Moment in Time hintergründet. Aber so ein sehr langsames Gesicht in sich zusammenfallen. Herrlich. Ich war letzte Woche beim Comedypreis,
wo wir gerade davon sprechen. Wow!
Toll, wieder schön die Currywurst
abgegriffen und schönes Mac-Café-Kuchen.
Oh mein Gott, nee, Moxa-Café
gab es diesmal, Kölner, Kölner Marke
und Currywurst gab es wieder,
stimmt, völlig richtig. War nicht so
lecker, wobei, ehrlich gesagt,
wir sind nach einer Drei-Stunden-Veranstaltung sitzen,
wo man ja auch vom Lachen dann schon ganz hungrig geworden ist, da macht das schon mal Spaß. Ja, wie immer, grauenhaft und das nicht so passt. Wer hat gewonnen? Wie immer, Karolin Kebekus. Und alles gewonnen. Karolin Kebekus und Dieter Nuhr. Dieter Nuhr war nicht da. Hat sich gegenseitig Preise gegeben. Dieter Nur ist nicht mehr da. Nee? Nee. Weder da, physisch. Muss er sich nach seinem Shitstorm jetzt zurückziehen, oder was? Ich weiß nicht genau. Er ist weder physisch da, noch für irgendwas nominiert. Dieter Nur ist einfach nicht mehr existent. Aber was ich das Lustigste fand an dem Abend, und das Verwunderste, dann gab es die besten Komiker als Preis. Und dann gab es ja, am Ende sieht man dann immer, wer da ist und wer nicht da ist. Die, auf die die Kameras zeigen, die sind dann da und dann werden die eingeblendet, die dann immer noch lachen tun müssen, wenn die verloren haben, trotzdem. Und wer war nicht da, was man sah, weil ein Foto eingeblendet war, Ralf Schmitz. Und ich dachte mir, das ist sein Job. Dieser Abend, es gibt, warum ist Ralf Schmitz nicht hier? Was hat Ralf Schmitz gerade vor? Was macht Ralf Schmitz am Abend des Deutschen Comedypreises? Das ist doch sein Abend. Das ist seine Veranstaltung. Wo ist Ralf Schmitz? Ich meine, wenn nicht mal Ralf Schmitz Bock hat auf Comedypreis hat. Was mache ich dann hier?
Was ist das für eine Anstaltung eigentlich?
Ja.
Das fand ich höchstens verwirrend. Ich meine, wenn nicht mal Ralf Schmitz Bock hat auf Comedypreis hat. Wenn nicht mal mehr Ralf Schmitz Bock hat auf Comedypreis. Was mache ich dann hier?
Was ist das für eine Anstaltung eigentlich?
Ja.
Das fand ich höchstens verwirrend.
Ralf Schmitz war nicht da.
Und hat er gewonnen?
Nee.
Ist ja egal.
Es kann auch nie der gewinnen, der nicht da ist.
Das ist immer so ein bisschen.
Doch, es sind aber häufig Dinge gewonnen, die nicht da sind.
Ja, genau, aber die treffen sich ja erst am, die Jury trifft sich ja erst am Tag des Comedypreises.
Gibt es was Demütigenderes, als anwesend zu sein? Als einziger vier Nominierte und nur Annette Frier ist anwesend und alle irgendwie Martina Hill, Caroline Kebelkos, alle anderen sind nicht da. Und sie ist als einziger anwesend und gewinnt trotzdem nicht. Ja, war so bei Maren Kreumann. Die einzige Frau in der Kategorie und die einzige, die da war, nicht gewonnen. Oh nein! Und wer hat gewonnen? Christian Ulmen in einer anderen Kategorie mit Jerks und Fariadim. Und die haben, waren nicht da, haben gewonnen und haben nicht mal eine Videobotschaft aufgenommen. Sehr gut. Als Dankeschön. Und dann musste der Comedypreis so ganz schlecht einen Sketch schreiben, wie zwei Comedypreise sich unterhalten, so ganz schlecht animiert auch, wo sie sich darüber echauffieren, so ein bisschen Spitzen auch gegen die schießen, dass sie nicht auftauchen. Und dann Kristall gesagt, kommt doch mal rum, ist ganz schön hier. Dann hat er den Preis mitgenommen. Jetzt hat Kristall den Preis. Und wird ihn wahrscheinlich auch behalten. Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass da nochmal jemand hinkommt und diesen Preis abholt. Aber das fand ich ganz. Ich habe letztens nochmal einen Christian-Ulmen-Tag gemacht. Viele unter Ulmen, Ulmens Auftrag nochmal angeschaut auf YouTube, da kann man sich echt durchklicken. Weil YouTube ist ja auch gnadenlos einfach so. Wenn du den einen Suchbegriff gibst, dann dominiert YouTube einfach den Rest seines Tages und sagt, du willst das, was Christian Ulmen jemals produziert hat, sehen? Bitteschön, hier ist es, und dann schaue ich mir auch alles an. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass YouTube aber auch ein bisschen dafür zu meiner Stagnation beiträgt, weil YouTube kennt jetzt so hundert Videos, die mir sehr gut gefallen haben, die mir so gut gefallen haben, dass ich nochmal neu geguckt habe. Und deswegen werden die mir immer wieder neu vorgeschlagen, immer wieder, weil YouTube will ja sich Zeit auf der Plattform verbringen und die Videos, die mir gefallen und die ich mir nochmal angeschaut habe, werden mir wieder vorgeschlagen, immer wieder, weil YouTube will ja, dass ich Zeit auf der Plattform verbringe und die Videos, die mir gefallen und ich mir noch mal angeschaut habe, werden wieder vorgeschlagen, weil es kann ja sein, dass ich dadurch dann mehr Zeit auf der Seite verbringe. Und deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, entwirke ich mich auch intellektuell und was meine Interessen anbelangt nicht mehr weiter, weil YouTube einfach sagt, ich glaube, ich gucke nur hundert Videos im S. So. Die, die, die kennen mehr Video, die kenne ich auch gar nicht. Die werden mir jetzt angezeigt immer wieder und die schaue ich immer wieder. Es gibt wirklich so eine Rotation irgendwie, ich glaube, also dieses, dieses Shia LaBeouf von Rock Gesundheit. Ja, wurde mir auch noch nicht vorgeschlagen. Schaue ich mir einmal im Monat an, seit Jahren, seit Jahren, seit Jahren, das ist eines der hundert Videos. Immer und immer wieder, es ist einfach eines der besten Videos im Internet, es ist einfach so.
Es funktioniert einfach immer, ist immer wieder gut, ich schaue es mir immer wieder an. Ja, dann Jeff Goldblum, ja, ein Video von Jeff Goldblum. Natürlich, gucke ich mir immer an, dann dieser Dialekt-Coach von Wyatt, jeden Monat gucke ich mir alle Teile an. Ja.
Ich kenne es mittlerweile schon, aber ich gucke es mir immer wieder an.
Ja, Diphtong.
Wenn man zwei Buchstaben verbindet, I. Ja. Diphtongs. Diphthong. Immer wichtig. Gucke ich mir jede Woche immer wieder an. Es ist einfach grossartig. Es ist immer wieder toll. Die eine Nordkorea-Doku, die man dabei hat. Ja, herrlich, die muss sein, die muss sein. Ja, das sind so die paar Videos, die man hat und das ist auch irgendwie, ich glaube, das war mal anders bei mir. Ich habe da mal, man war dann in einer neuen Lebensphase, das kommt nicht mehr. Übrigens, ich habe den Fluch gebrochen. Ich habe den Fluch gebrochen, wir haben ja vor, glaube ich, zwei Wochen drüber geredet, dass Dinge, die einem empfohlen werden, man generell nicht anschaut. Ja. Ich habe den Fluch gebrochen, ich habe Fleabag angeschaut. Du hast mir empfohlen, angeschaut, beide Staffeln durchgeschaut, holy fucking crap, ist diese Serie gut. Oh mein Gott. Wow. Es ist wirklich, es ist, genauso wie du es beschrieben hast, es macht einen wütend, wie gut diese Serie ist. Man denkt sich, das darf doch nicht wahr sein. Vor allem, du hast andere Serien, die du magst und plötzlich denkst du dir, im Vergleich sind die nicht gut, aber ich mag die trotzdem noch. Alle Serien sind scheiss bis dato. Ich habe diese Serie gemocht und jetzt sehe ich diese andere Serie, die viel besser ist, als ob dir dein Kind weggenommen wird, weil du ein besseres Kind hast und du denkst, aber das alte Kind mochte ich auch mal und jetzt nicht, jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr mögen. Ja, es ist wie, man hat so eine Lüge gelebt bis dato. Dinge, die man für gut gehalten hat, waren es vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt. Ja, es hat meine ganze, genau, und Phoebe Waller-Bridge, ich habe mich total in die verliebt, ganz tolle Frau. Grossartig. Ich habe alle Videos auch von ihr mittlerweile geschaut, alle Interviews geschaut. Ich bin kurz davor, mir Solo anzuschauen. Kurz davor. Noch nicht ganz da, aber dann machst du dir viel kaputt. Aber kurz davor. Dann machst du dir viel kaputt. Kurz davor. Aber absolut fantastische Serie, wirklich macht alles richtig. Also es ist ja wirklich so, selbst Serien, die man gut findet, denkt man sich so, na, eine Sache gibt es nicht so gut, aber das ist wirklich ein winziger, winziger Teil. Aber absolut grandios und auch viele Tropen, wo man denkt, die habe ich schon tausend Mal gesehen, gerade diese Fourth Wall, irgendwie jetzt nach House of Cards. So original und toll. Und du denkst dir immer so, das haben wir jetzt schon langsam verstanden, irgendwie ich gucke in die Kamera, aber es ist so fucking gut nochmal gemacht. Und das ist so auch als Bogen durchgezogen, dieses ganze Stil. Und daran merkt man ja auch, dass es ja nicht aus dem Nichts kommt, diese Idee, sondern es basiert ja auch dem Theaterstück aus einer One-Woman-Show, die sie dann später auch immer am Broadway und am und am London Western gespielt hat und so.
Und da redet sie halt die ganze Zeit zum Publikum und spielt halt alle anderen Rollen und kommentiert halt die Situation. Eigentlich ist die erste Staffel komplett dieser eine Abend, diese eine One Woman Show, die auch teilweise jetzt in Kinos zu sehen war. Ja, krass. Ja, waren ein paar Kollegen auch da. Und das ist ganz interessant, interessant weil daher kam die idee einfach das zu kommentieren zwischendurch weil sie ja auch nicht wusste wie baut man das ist zu einer serie um und daher kam das und das ist total gegen organisch entstanden und ich finde dadurch merkt man auch so eine so eine idee an dass sie das ist total und innovativ damit sofort auch immer cool ja das ist nicht einfach nur ein Gimmick. Wahnsinn. Und vor kurzem hat Andy Bardet auch nochmal gepostet, dass das ja alles als Kickstarter-Kampagne angefangen hat. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es sich auf das Theaterstück bezieht, ich glaube fast sogar schon, oder darauf aus, dem Theaterstück eine Serie zu machen. Aber es ist schon geil zu sehen, jetzt wo die halt 100 Emmys gewonnen hat und irgendwie vor fünf Jahren war es ein Kickstarter oder so, richtig
krass, also
alles selber geschrieben von ihr auch, also
ja, und die spielt das auch fantastisch toll,
ich bin da auch ganz verliebt, ich finde das eine ganz, ganz, ganz,
ganz fantastische Serie, beide Staffeln
auch, unglaublich cool besetzt auch,
ach, supergut,
auch tolle Schauspieler, auch Riesenschauspieler
dafür, dass es aus dem Nichts kam, ein bisschen mit Oliver Coleman und Andrew Scott und so.
Wahnsinn gut, aber vielen Dank für diese Empfehlung.
Gerne, schaut auf jeden Fall mal in Fliebeck rein.
Ich bin gespannt auf die nächste Empfehlung. Ich glaube, du hast einen Riecher.
Aber habe ich mir jetzt zumindest drei Empfehlungen wieder rausgeholt damit, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe tatsächlich ja mit einem Rocket Beans TV Mitarbeiter einen Pakt geschlossen, dass alle Dinge, die wir uns gegenseitig empfehlen, wir anschauen müssen. Müssen, müssen, müssen. Müssen es anschauen. Wie viel Schwachsinn musstest du dir angucken? Genau, und wir haben es eine Runde durchgehalten. Ich habe ihm Paddleton empfohlen, fand er so mittelmässig.
Er hat mir die Beyonce-Doku empfohlen, fand ich auch so mittelmässig und dann haben wir es gelassen, weil wir beide so gesagt haben, lassen wir es. Na ja gut, aber ja, man kann sich ja verarschen irgendwann, ne? Ja, stimmt schon. Ich dachte, ihr seid nicht mehr bis zu dem Bruch gekommen. Nee, tatsächlich doch. Schau dir mal den Pikachu-Film an.
Nicht mal bis dahin seid ihr gekommen. Nee, nee, nee, weil das ist ja, da reisst eine Mauer ein, da kommt ein Damm. Ja, ja. Da reisst ein Damm ein. Der Damm bröckelt, der Damm bricht. Bricht. Ja, das ist schon interessant. Warum fließt ein Damm nicht über? Warum fließen nicht alle Seen immer über? Das ist ja ein Fluss, aber die haben schon ein Loch drin, ne? Im Damm. Aber die wollen es nur einmal aufstauen, damit die eine Stadt bauen können. Es kommt ein bisschen auf, ja, darauf an, warum man diesen Damm baut, oder? Gibt es nicht auch Dämme, die man baut, um Energie zu erzeugen? Ja, damit das alles runterfällt. Das Wasser fällt runter. Das Wasser fällt runter. Und man pumpt ja Wasser auch wieder hoch, wenn man zu viel Energie hat. Zum Beispiel Atomkraftwerke erzeugen ja immer dieselbe Menge Energie, egal wie viel gebraucht wird. Und wenn man weniger braucht, als das Atomkraftwerk Strom erzeugt, dann nutzt man dieses überschrüssige Strom, um Wasser hochzupumpen, damit es oben ist. Damit, wenn man was braucht, man das Wasser wieder runterfallen lassen kann, damit es dann Strom erzeugt. Dafür sind ja auch diese Wassertürme in den USA da, die man überall in diesen Kleinstädten immer sieht. Ja, die sind toll. Ja, diese riesen Wassertürme. Ja. Einfach um, der Mensch mag Wasser oben. Ja, Wasser oben ist einfach das Beste. Ja, Wasser oben ist so, und da gibt die Menschen das Herz auf. Der Mensch hat es auch der Natur nie verziehen, dass man nicht Regen machen kann. Ach so. Dass Wasser unten ist und nach unten will und es nicht regnen kann. Ja. Ich nicht immer regnen kann. Ja. Ich liebe Regen. Ich liebe Wasser oben. Aber da bin ich bisher nicht alleine. Werbung Nein, gibt es nicht. Na klar, es gibt auch gut recherchierte, journalistisch aufgearbeitete Podcasts, bei denen man viel lernen kann über verschiedene Themen. Nein. Ich nenne dir mal ein Beispiel. Ja, nenne mir ein Beispiel. Naja, zum Beispiel das Thema von der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Ja, du kennst die Süddeutsche Zeitung als anspruchsvolle Zeitung, aber die machen auch fantastische Podcasts. Die sprechen über ganz verschiedene Themen, wie zum Beispiel Marslandung, ja, Weltraumthemen oder Macrons Politik für Europa, ganz viele verschiedene Themen. Du meinst, es gibt einen gut recherchierten Podcast? Ja, da wird richtig mal in die Tiefe gegangen, nicht nur so oberflächlich umgekratzt, sondern da wird richtig gegraben. Und wo kann ich das, kann ich das hören? Ja, überall, wo du deine Podcasts hören kannst, auf Spotify, iTunes, einfach nach Das Thema suchen oder für eine Übersicht für alle Podcasts der SZ, einfach sz.de slash podcast, da findet ihr nämlich noch ganz viele andere tolle Podcasts. Und der kommt jetzt irgendwie einmal im Jahr, oder was? Nein, jeden Mittwoch. Nein, jeden Mittwoch. Mittwoch, du magst doch Mittwoch. Ich liebe den Mittwoch, das ist mein Lieblingswochentag. Jede Woche eine neue Folge. Okay, alles klar, dann sag mir nochmal einmal, wo ich alle Informationen finden kann, dann bin ich zufrieden. Also, das Thema sz.de schrägstrich das Thema für den Podcast, das Themavestigativer-Journalismus. Ganz fantastisch. Mega cool. Vielen Dank, Florian. Und jetzt zurück zu unserem dummen Scheiss-Laber-Podcast. Keine, gar keine Informationen. Macht jetzt aus. Null. Viel Spaß. Werbung. Was mich brennend interessiert, ist, bist du mit der Kühlschrankfrage weitergekommen? Letzte Woche hat Flur die spannende Frage gestellt, an niemanden, einfach an sich selbst, wie viel, an die Wissenschaft, aber er wollte es auch nicht von der Wissenschaft beantwortet haben. Also, ja, eine denkbar schwierige Konstellation für den Podcast, dennoch bin ich sehr interessiert, er wollte herausfinden, wie viel Energie sein Kühlschrank verbraucht. Und ab wann es sinnvoll ist, welchen Zeitraum, Zeitintervall es Sinn macht, den Kühlschrank doch lieber auszuschalten. Richtig, richtig. Bist du weitergekommen? Ich bin weitergekommen, und zwar, es hat mir niemand gespoilert, aber mir wurde Equipment empfohlen, dass ich nutzen kann, um das aufzuzeichnen, und da habe ich mir was bestellt. Lass mich raten, Bedienungsanleitung, that's it. Ich habe zu viel Geld ausgegeben, aber so ist das nun mal, so sind solche Projekte und ich bin ein Technikfreak, also ich mag das so blöd. Du bist nur ein Dingstechnikfreak, du bist kein Technikfreak. Ja, die schon immer, aber fricken und ich habe mir jetzt Equipment geholt und. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, was für Equipment kam denn da? Also erst mal ein Strommessgerät, dann dachte ich mir, okay, das zeichnet das dann auf, kannst du mit einer App verbinden, dann habe ich mein Betriebssystem, war zu alt, dann musste ich mir noch ein neues Handy kaufen. Bitte, was ist los? Brauchst du einen Thermometer, damit ich auch noch die Temperatur messen kann in der Küche, Luftdruck musst du messen, das muss auch alles aufgezeichnet werden, dann dachte ich mir, mache ich einen zentralen, progriere ich da so ein Anduino-Ding irgendwie, programmiere ich das, dass der irgendwie dann irgendwie die Messwerte aufschreibt, wie kriege ich die Daten da rein und am Ende ist es ein bisschen viel geworden. Wahrscheinlich werde ich es nie auspacken und weiterhin mein eine Senfglas im Kühlschrank haben, wo ich mir auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin, ob das überhaupt in den Kühlschrank gehört. Können wir auf Produkten bitte einfach ein Zeichen einführen, muss in den Kühlschrank, muss nicht in den Kühlschrank? Ganz einfach, ich will einfach so eine Frostflocke oder keine Frostflocke, einfach um klar zu sagen, Eier werden im Supermarkt ungekühlt verkauft, im Kühlschrank ist ein Eierfach. Wo, was, was geschieht? Wohin mit den Eiern, ja. Marmelade, auch das Gleiche. Normalerweise ist die Regel, finde ich, einfach, wenn man es gekühlt kauft, soll man es kühlen. Easy. Aber Eier ist so ein Mittelding. Leute, manchmal stellen Leute Nutella in den Kühlschrank, Senf, ich habe jetzt Senf im Kühlschrank. Nutella im Kühlschrank ist ja Blasphemie.
Weiss niemand.
Da wird sehr hart und irr. Weiss niemand. Niemand weiss das. Ich habe mich in der Zwischenzeit gefragt, wenn du theoretisch in der Lage bist, ihn einfach auszumachen, den Kühlschrank, kannst du ja nicht so viele Gegenstände im Kühlschrank haben. Wie ich die kenne, hast du auch nicht so viel im Kühlschrank. Nee, in meinem Kühlschrank sind drei Objekte. So, Frage. Jemand, der sich so viele Gedanken gemacht hat, wie er Energie sparen kann, wie du jetzt, der aber nur drei Dinge im Kühlschrank hat, kommt eher auf die Idee, sich sehr viel Equipment zu kaufen, um zu messen, wann es Sinn macht, den Kühlschrank auszumachen, anstatt einfach auf den Kühlschrank zu verzichten. Warum?
Ich brauche den Kühlschrank halt von Tag zu Tag. So, ich kaufe mir irgendwie einen schönen Lachs oder so und dann will ich den halt erst am nächsten Tag essen. Kauf dir genug Lachs.
Oder ich will eine schöne Mate, die soll kalt sein oder mal so einen schönen Dr. Pepper oder ich brauche Eiswürfel, um mir irgendwie meine Vitamin C-Tabletten ein bisschen aufzuhören. Aber du hast auch einen Eiskühlschrank, ne? Mit Gefrierfach integriert. Ja, das kannst du ja nicht separieren. Ja, habe ich auch. Kannst du nicht separieren. Nein, und das ist, glaube ich, der größte Energiefresser, weil da ist das Türchen kaputt. Und ich glaube, da suppt Kälte raus. Aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Eine absolute Katastrophe. Ganz kurz, die Top drei Produkte, die ich in meinem Kühlschrank habe, auf Platz drei. Ich habe gar nichts mehr im Kühlschrank. Die Top drei Produkte, die immer im Kühlschrank sind, auf Platz drei Mandelmilch. Immer im Kühlschrank? Ich habe nicht Dinge immer im Kühlschrank, nichts dann. Ich habe drei Dinge im Kühlschrank und die auch immer. Bei mir auf Platz drei Sojasauce.
Hab ich nie. Braucht man, man muss dabei sein. Kommt auch immer mit. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich habe auch mittlerweile einen relativ beachtlichen Vorrat an diesen Schütten. Ja, es kommt zu viel mit. Ja, ich habe auch, ich sammle, ich hebe auch diese Essstäbchen auf. Ja, da habe ich auch ganz viele davon. Kommt auch immer zu viele mit. Wirklich so, wenn man. Weil ich Da fiel mich immer beleidigt, weil deren Packaging sagt, das ist zu viel für eine Person. Ja, stimmt. Ich habe tatsächlich einmal für mich Essen alleine bestellt und ich habe vier Paar Stäbchen. Oh Gott, willkommen. Gott, vier. Also ich kann verstehen, dass wenn jemand irgendwie keine Ahnung was bestellt und dann denkt man sich, lieber einen zu viel, ja, lieber zwei. aber vier, apropos Empfehlungen, in Köln hat die fantastischste Rahmenrestaurant aufgemacht, ich darf, ich will aber nicht verraten, wie es heißt, weil ich will einfach nicht, dass Leute da hingehen. Du willst da alleine sein? Sorry, ganz eigenes. Du willst da nicht gestalkt werden, oder was? Nein, nein, nein, das ist mir scheißegal. Du willst nicht, dass du die Nudel aufsaugst und am anderen Ende, Nudelende ist ein Podcast. Nein, das ist mir scheißegal. Gerne treffe ich da Fans, aber ich will nicht, dass Leute in dieses Restaurant gehen, mehr. Das ist eh schon sehr beliebt in Überlaufen. Ich will nicht, dass da noch mehr hingehen. Das hat gerade erst aufgemacht, die am ersten Abend wurden die so überrammt, dass sie erst mal fünf Tage dicht gemacht haben. Ich will nicht, dass da Leute noch mehr hingehen. Wir sind müde. Ja, wir können nicht mehr, sorry. Nach dem ersten Tag, deswegen will ich den Namen nicht erwähnen, aber Mega Ramen. Ramen? Ramen, das war ganz toll. Ich hatte noch nie vier Stäbchen. Auf Platz zwei ist bei mir Putenbrust. Ich habe immer geschnitten Putenbrust. Super gesund, super lecker. Aber reden wir jetzt von dünnen Scheiben oder von schon so Brocken? Dünnen Scheibchen. Die dann so gefaltet sind? Genau, entweder Geräuch... Ne, die sind gestapelt. Meist geräuchert, gibt es aber auch gebraten. Bei mir auf Platz zwei, Jalapenos. Ich habe immer schön ein Glas Jalapenos offen, weil ich esse immer Nudeln mit Jalapenos zusammen und deswegen immer Glas Jalapenos.
Und ich habe die auch gehamstert, weil die roten sind die besten und es gibt eine Marke, die sind die besten, rote Jalapenos-Scheiben und die gab es einmal in meinem Supermarkt.
Dann habe ich alle Gläser gekauft und seitdem habe ich einen Stash und da esse ich immer so ein Paar davon, deswegen immer in der Hinterhand.
Oder schluss eins Eier. Eier ist ein Allrounder, kann man immer gebrauchen, ist nicht das kreativste Top-Eins, aber wirklich, du kannst sehr viel damit machen. Rüh-Eier, Spiegeleier, nur um zwei zu nennen. Aber du könntest noch mehr nennen. Omelette, Eggs Benedict, nur um vier zu nennen. Ja, es ist aber alles ein Ei, je nachdem wie heftig man es schüttelt. Ein Spiegelei ist gar nicht geschüttelt, ein Rührei ist stark geschüttelt, es sind nicht wirklich unterschiedliche Gerichte, man kann es nicht so sagen. Ich finde das ein bisschen faul. Du kannst aber auch mit Mehl was vermengen, Ei und dann hast du ein anderes Gericht. Da kannst du es auch nicht mit der Florentin-Will-Pauke umherschlagen. Das ist dann ein neues Gericht. Wie viele Eier kannst du gleichzeitig öffnen?
Gleichzeitig öffnen? Warum ist das
ein Skill, den man erlernen sollte? Eins.
Einen? Ist okay.
Ist gut. Ist über
im Durchschnitt.
Bei uns in der Familie gab es eine Legende,
die geraunt wurde von Generation zu Generation.
Das glaube ich mein
Grossonkel,
der Konditor war, der konnte vier Eier gleichzeitig öffnen. In jeder Hand zwei und dann auf den Tisch hauen und dann jeweils aufmachen. Mit beiden Händen, in jeder Hand zwei, vier gleichzeitig. Du willst aber auch nicht als der Mensch eingehen in die Annalen, der das kann. Oder wenn das dein Skill ist, wenn das dein Skill ist, dann hast du aber nicht, was war, das ist schon ziemlich cool. Ja, ist cool. Nee, verstehe mich nicht falsch. Wofür gehst du in die Geschichte ein, dass du deinen Rachen verschluckt hast? Ich bin der, der in der Winter erkannt hat, dass man nicht seine Nasenflügel innerhalb zumachen kann im Mund. Nee, aber ich verstehe schon, dass es ein bisschen aggressiv ist jetzt auch, weil es ja auch um deine Vorfahren geht und so, aber ist das denn so ein toller Skill? Also dann hat er ja, willst du dich eher für den besten Kuchen Deutschlands?
Nein, ich finde das richtig cool. Wenn man eine Hand hat, denke ich mir, wow, vier und sich wirklich so viel Vertrauen in seine Fähigkeiten zu haben, dass man keine Schalenstücke drin haben will, das ist schon beeindruckend.
Oh, Schalenstücke sind ganz gefährlich, hast du es nicht erzählt?
Das ist aber ein ganz, ganzes Werk, nee, hat Julia keine Schalenstücke drin haben will. Das ist schon beeindruckend. Oh, Schalenstücke sind ganz gefährlich. Hast du das nicht erzählt? Kalk. Das hat man ganz, ganz weg. Nee, hat Julia Becker erzählt. Kalk? Ist das Kalk? Ja, nee. Die reissen den Darm auf, ne? So war das. Reissen den Darm auf, ja. Kalk ist der letztlich glaube ich nicht so gut. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was das ist. Aber ist das wie Fingernagel eigentlich, oder ist das so wie... Nee, das ist Horn. Horn? Das ist Horn. Das sind ja wie abgestorbene Haare. Ach, jetzt sind wir wieder off track, off road. Anderes Thema, anderes Thema.
Aber ich glaube, derselbe Onkel hatte auch eine große Waffensammlung.
Und der ist irgendwann mal gestorben.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was aus dieser Waffensammlung geworden ist.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich da einmal war und ich war überwältigt.
Weil normalerweise als Kind Verwandte besuchen, in der Regel eher ein bisschen.
Langweilig.
Und man denkt sich einfach nur, okay, es gibt eine einzige Sache, die ich bei meinen Verwandten tun kann, die Süßigkeiten-Schublade suchen. Das ist es halt. Und dann sucht man, sucht man und dann irgendwann hat man sie gefunden und denkt sich, okay, zart, hart, bitter, Schokolade, fuck, aber schiebe ich mir trotzdem rein. Okay, aber gut, es ist der Nachmittag, ist um. Und da hat er halt irgendwie eine grosse Waffensammlung mit Säbel und Granaten. Und man sucht die Süßigkeiten-Tippel und entdeckt die Walter-Pippe-Kar und denkt sich, bitte was? Die SS-Uniform. Moment mal. Den Schrank machen wir mal wieder zu. Du neugierige Naseweiss. Der ist Aha! Nein, das ist Alois Hallhuber. Das ist ein Freund gewesen. So, jetzt machen wir mal den Schrank zu. Hier hast du ein After-Aid. Ja, oh, After-Aid, immer sehr gut. Viel in Altenheimen. Wenn ihr sagt, ich gehe nicht gerne in Altenheime, dann habt ihr eure Liebe zu After-Aid noch nicht gefunden. Wollt man da nicht mal einen After-Aid-Dispenser aufstellen? Wie man das kennt von so Pets. Ach ja, stimmt. Das finde ich schön für After-Aid, dass man sie so ziehen kann. Wie so ein Kondomautomat, dass alles nach Notfall aussieht. Ich finde, je mehr es nach Notfall aussieht... Wie so Warteschlankzettel, wo man einfach... Je mehr diese After-Aids-Pets nach Notfall aussieht, so ich brauche jetzt eins, desto besser. Das sollte man vielleicht mal aufhängen. Oder auch so wie mit so Pokerchips, dann so Stapelspiele mit so diesen After-Aids. Dann wird Ränder. Dann wird es so eine Währung wie so Zigaretten im Knast. Ja. Und dann haben die so, und dann hat dieser alte Mann in der Ecke, der schon länger da ist, der schon tot geglaubt ist, der hat dann sehr viele After-Aids, der hat 20 After-Aids. Der könnte jeden haben, der könnte jeden kaufen. Zum Beispiel mit Papierstreifen umwickelt, Stapel dann einfach so. Und natürlich du in deinem hässlichen Klemmding, dazu zerrücken die natürlich alle. Da drücken die alle, ja. Das ist natürlich schwierig. Ganz kurz, können wir über Zartbitterschokolade reden? Was für ein perverses Aufrüsten ist eigentlich da gerade am Laufen? Ich habe so ein Werbeplakat gesehen und dann irgendwie 76% Kakao, dann 82% Kakao, wo ich mir denke, 120
Prozent Kakao? Wirklich so
irgendwie, was, also warum,
das ist auch einfach so
ein Wettrüsten, wo dann
irgendwie Milka gegen Haribo oder so, man
dann einfach kämpft und sagt, wir haben noch zwei Prozent mehr
Kakao und denkst so, Kakao
ist nicht das Geile an Schokolade, mal ganz
kurz. Ja, aber genau, genau, es ist nicht wie bei
Ecstasy, dass der Part, wo man denkt immer, dass es der gefährliche Part, gar nicht der schlimme ist, der Wirkstoff von Ecstasy, MDMA, ist ja gar nicht der Part, der interessant ist, sondern der andere, mit dem es gestreckt ist, Kokain, Speed und so einen Scheiss, Koffein. Der macht dich ja fit und das andere macht dich ja nur gut gelaunt quasi und vielleicht kannst du nicht so gut schlafen. Aber bei Schokolade ist es doch genauso. Der Part, der dich nämlich, der dich glücklich macht, ist doch der Kakao-Part. Ja. Aber der Part, der dich dick macht, ist doch der Vollmilch-Part. Eigentlich schon, ich habe es nicht verstanden. Vor allem, ich denke mir, wenn, also. Aber das ist doch dann erstrebenswert, den Vollmilchpart klein zu halten, den Milchpart und den Kakaopart gross. Ich finde, die rätselhafteste Sorte ist ja die in der Mitte. Also entweder du sagst, ich mag Kakao oder ich mag keinen Kakao, aber zu sagen, nee, 79% ist mir zu wenig, aber 92% ist mir zu viel, ich nehme die 86-prozentige. Denkst du, wie präzise muss ein Mensch sein Kakao-Lust definieren können, dass wir sagen, ich nehme genau die. Ich verstehe auch nicht, wie man überhaupt auf diese Kalorienanzahl dahin kommt. Bei Schokolade oder was? Bei allem. Ich verstehe es nicht. Es ist so lächerlich genau. Es ist wirklich lächerlich genau. Genau. Ich verstehe nicht, wie man auf die Zahl 172 Kalorien pro 100 Milliliter kommen kann. Wie soll das bitte funktionieren? Wie wäre das denn? Naja, du weißt ja, was Zucker für Kalorien hat und was Milch für Kalorien hat und dann guckst du halt das Verhältnis. Das ist unmöglich so genau machen. Vor allem das Gaste ist ja, ich habe lange, als ich in Berlin gewohnt habe, habe ich mich immer mit Pop-Tarts versorgt, weil im Karstadt da gab es Pop-Tarts und die hatten Kalorien pro 100 Gramm 400 Kalorien. Und weißt du, was auch 400 Kalorien pro 100 Gramm hat? Zucker. Die hatten auf die Kalorie exakt genau, genau so viel Kalorien wie reiner Zucker. Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, wie kann was, also ich meine, die bestehen ja nicht zu 100% aus Zucker, wie geht das denn?
Naja, aber der Keks hat ja auch einen Kalorienanteil.
Ja, aber du schreibst ja das Produkt insgesamt.
Wenn du sagst, Keks ... Ja, ja, da kommt auch noch was hinzu.
Plus Butter und so hat ja auch im Schnitt mehr als 400 Kalorien wahrscheinlich. Aber ich fand es einfach verrückt, dass es wirklich exakt genau die gleiche Kalorien anzupassen. Also wirklich auf die Kalorie genau. Es wirkt wie ein Joke. Wahnsinn. Es wirkt merkwürdig. Es wirkt wie wie, ja, praktisch Zucker, also als ob das ja... Ja, das ist im Grunde Zucker. Es fühlt sich auch so an wie so ein Sweetspot, dass die wirklich das ausgerechnet haben, dass vielleicht es genau richtig ist. Genau 400 Kalorien? Genau 400, wo ich mir denke, das kann doch kein Zufall sein. Ja, das denke ich mir auch, warum ist nicht hinten alles gerundet? Also diese 172, das verstehe ich immer nicht. Wo kommen denn diese zwei her? Ja, aber ich, also Kochen ist ja auch viel Willkür. Also ob du jetzt den Kuchen mit 120... Ja, aber industriell ja nicht. Genau, und dann, glaube ich, kann man sich vielleicht an sowas orientieren, dass man sagt, wir treffen genau viel halt Kälte. Ja, aber da sind doch teilweise natürliche Produkte drin. Die können ja unmöglich immer das Gleiche haben. Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, wie man überhaupt auf diese super klare Zahl kommt. Weil wenn du ein Avocado da reinballerst, dann weißt du ja auch nicht, es ist Avocado hat ja gleich viel, verstehst du? Sobald was Natürliches hinzukommt, ist es ja die Größe ja seltsam.
Schwierig, schwierig, da verstehst du auch nicht.
schwierig. Ich bin vor allem, also Kochen funktioniert normalerweise so, dass man, man kocht was und dann bewertet man es und dann macht man Änderungen. Also man sagt
übrigens, keine Ahnung, jetzt Kuchen mit drei Eiern, oh der war ein bisschen eiig, beim nächsten
mal zwei und dann sagt man zwei ist zu wenig und dann so kommt man halt, wird man immer besser Koch. Und ich koche ab und zu. Ja, wenn du vorausgesst alle anderen Variablen weißt du noch. Ist ein sehr kompliziertes Thema, völlig richtig. Aber jetzt brechen wir es mal runter auf einfache Dinge. Und ich mache mir ganz gern Spaghetti Aglio Olio. Aglio Olio. Knoblauch. Und auch, ja, mehr Knoblauch, ein bisschen weniger Knoblauch, um den perfekten Knoblauchmöglichen zu treffen. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin meilenweit, meilenweit vom richtigen Knoblauchpunkt entfernt. Aber du weißt nicht, ob es mehr oder weniger. Ich weiss, dass es definitiv zu viel ist. Zu viel ist. Also ich habe irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, erst neun Knoblauchzehen. Das ist fucking viel zu viel. Nächstes Mal acht. Das ist immer noch brutals zu viel. Sieben. Wahrscheinlich ist die richtige Anzahl so eine halbe oder so. Und ich arbeite nämlich von zehn abwärts. Aber warum machst du keine grösseren Schritte? Weil du kannst ja bei zehn massiv zu viel, kennst du dich ja besser. Ich habe das Gefühl, man muss erst drei kleine Schritte gehen, um zu merken,
du musst in Fünfer-Schritten dich bewegen,
sonst kommen wir ja nicht voran. Und vor allem habe ich immer gelernt,
eher Pendel.
Mach doch mal dann viel zu wenig.
Also dann irgendwie von zehn auf null
und dann sagen wir, ein Viertel ist zu wenig.
Aber vielleicht ein Viertel.
Sondern schauen wir mal.
Und wahrscheinlich ist ein Viertel,
mit Sicherheit könnte, also ich bin sicher, dass zehn nicht richtig ist, aber ein Viertel schon sehr nah an der Menge ist, die du brauchst. Und irgendwann habe ich mir auch überlegt, und da bin ich dann überhaupt nicht mehr auf. Neunzehn? Es ist ein bisschen arg viel. Für eine Portion? Naja, woher weiss man dann, was der Richtige ist? Du riechst an deiner Zehe, das ist so intensiv, das funktioniert nicht. Ja, ich weiss nicht. Und vor allem allem irgendwann dachte ich mir, vielleicht mag ich auch einfach keinen Knoblauch. Also irgendwann denkt man sich, es gibt keine richtige Menge. Gibt es denn für alles immer die richtige Menge oder mag ich es einfach nicht? Weil wenn irgendwie, dann lasse ich es einfach weg und mache ein anderes Gericht. Aber es ist auch gut, dass du dann immer wieder zu dem Alio zurückkommst. Ja, ich denke mir, es ist so. Obwohl du nicht weißt, dass du vielleicht gar nicht
dieses Gericht magst. Das ist so ein Scheissgericht.
Also es ist lecker, aber
also wirklich, wenn man sich überlegt, manche
Köche machen dann irgendwie mit
Brathuhn und dann mit Panade
und dann steckt man was rein und das ist einfach
Nudeln, Öl, Knoblauch.
So fuck it einfach. Ich gehe mittlerweile
so oft essen, weil ich
habe mir überlegt, wer bin ich,
dass ich Essen mache? Was bilde ich mir ein?
Das macht keinen Sinn. Das ist Hochmut.
Du bist bescheiden geworden. Nee, ich kann gerne
kochen, aber dann breite ich mich auch drauf vor und so
dann ist Arbeit. Und so viel Zeit habe ich halt in der Woche nicht.
Aber wenn ich koche, dann nehme ich das auch ernst.
Und dann kaufe ich auch gerne viel ein. Ich freue mich auf dieses
Zutaten-Einkaufen für ein Gericht ist toll.
Damit du genau weißt, du bist nicht im Laden,
um dich zu versorgen, so vage, sondern einfach um das zu kaufen, was du brauchst.
Dann vergisst du was, dann gehst du zurück und du weißt, was du brauchst.
Das ist schön, aber dazu komme ich meistens nicht, deswegen gehe ich mittlerweile sehr gerne abends essen.
Weil ich bin mittlerweile, das ist der neue Stefan, der Lifestyle-Stefan, der, wenn er lange arbeitet am Tag, abends nicht nach Hause geht einfach und sich von Fenster setzt, sondern der sich was gönnt für die lange Arbeitszeit. Ich kann, und es ist wirklich auch mittlerweile tiefenpsychologisch veranlagt, ich kann abends nicht mehr ins Bett und nächsten Tag wieder normal aufstehen und zur Arbeit kommen. Kann ich nicht mehr. Es fühlt sich an, als würde ich das Leben wegwerfen. Deswegen muss ich abends dann, nach einem langen Arbeitstag, gehe ich noch schön essen. Du gehst essen, aber ist da auch dann mal so ein Kinobesuch dabei oder sowas? Manchmal Kinobesuch. Hauptsache, man tut sich etwas Gutes. Nee, finde ich gut. Eigentlich ist das wirklich ein Reflex, den man überdenken sollte. Oh, Arbeitstag geschafft, erstmal nach Hause. Erstmal nach Hause? Ja, weil dann macht man ja nichts mehr. Das war nicht, gar keine reflektierte Entscheidung. Es war ein reines, aber es fühlt sich falsch an, jetzt nach Hause zu gehen, womöglich dann vorm Fernseher einzuschlafen oder sowas und dann morgens wieder aufzubauen, um zur Arbeit zu gehen. Das fühlt sich einfach nicht richtig an. Und deswegen so ein schöner Abend irgendwo im Restaurant ist wirklich was Tolles. Kann es sein, dass dann auch mal so ein Abendspaziergang dabei ist? Oder so ein Schlendern durch die Stadt?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Schlendern durch die Stadt oder mal so ein bisschen.
Ein Kollege hat mir erzählt, er konnte nicht schlafen.
Und er ist dann rausgegangen um den Block.
Und ich dachte kurz, what?
Was?
Aber er ist ja ein erwachsener Mann, er kann ja diese Entscheidung treffen. Und dann fiel mir immer ein, ich kann viele Entscheidungen treffen, die ich noch nicht getroffen habe. Ich kann so viel machen. Das ist mir in dem Moment bei dieser lächerlichen Entscheidung, dass man nachts rausgehen kann, klar geworden, dass ich mein Leben noch nicht voll ausgenutzt habe. Man kann nachts, wenn man nicht schlafen kann, einfach rausgehen.
Auch wenn ich am nächsten, es ist so ein bisschen so, man hat noch die Eltern im Kopf, die sagen, du musst jetzt schlafen, du musst morgen fit sein.
Fuck you, wer seid ihr noch?
Ich bin 25, ich kann nachts rausgehen.
Ey, aber frische Luft hat das für mich eine Revolution.
Lüften habe ich jetzt für mich entdeckt. Also wirklich, ich bin jetzt an dem Punkt, wo ich Sauerstoff für mich entdecke, wo ich es einfach sage, ja, es ist schon, man braucht es einfach schon so. Bevor ich ins Bett gehe, noch mal kurz durchlüften, wunderbar, ganz fantastisch, großartig, gefällt mir richtig gut. Bei mir in der Strasse hat jetzt einen Supermarkt aufgemacht, der ist so suspekt. Also das ist ein so suspekter Supermarkt. Was, ist es eine Kette, eine grössere Kette, eine kleiner? Es ist keine Kette, kein einziger Kunde war da jemals drin. Du warst drin. Ich habe mich noch nicht getraut, aber es ist ein großes Schaufenster. Und was einem auffällt, und es ist wirklich, weil ich meine, also ich kenne mich ganz schlecht aus mit so urbanen Kriminalitätspolizei, blablabla, Zeug und so.
Aber wenn ich sagen müsste, wo wird Geld gewaschen, ich würde sagen, in diesem Supermarkt.
Weil dieser Supermarkt verkauft nur Dinge, die sich ewig halten lassen.
Ausschliesslich nur Reispackungen, Soßen, irgendwie Flaschen, kein einziges frisches Obst, kein einziges Gemüse, nichts dergleichen, kein Kühlschrank, kein Geflügel, nichts, kein Gefrierschrank, nichts tiefgekühltes, nur Regale, nur der Reihe nach Dinge aufgestapelt, Chips, dann so Tüten verschiedener Größe, Gewürzdinge, Gewürzmischungen, also Dinge, die man einmal einkauft, zehn Jahre im Regal stehen lassen kann und dann den Laden zumacht, weil man genug Geld gewaschen hat. Und ich bin fasziniert von diesem Laden. Und vielleicht gehe ich einfach mal rein. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Frag mal genau, waschen Sie hier Geld? Ja, genau. Und wenn ja. Das stimmt, das eigentlich könnte man fragen. Vielleicht sagt er einfach ja. Ja. Weil es ist, weil es ist so alles an dem Laden sagt ja, weil ich meine, die Polizei ist ja nicht komplett dumm, die sieht das und weiss ja, vielleicht kriegen die es irgendwie dann nicht hin, das dem genau zu nachzuweisen oder so, ich kenne mich da nicht aus, wie gesagt, aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich Leute, die sich damit auskennen, sehen ja sowas, aber man kriegt, man kann die ja nicht rund um die Uhr bewachen und dann die Kunden zählen und dann sagen, ihr habt viel weniger verdient, als ihr vorgeht.
Also genau wie bei mir in der Straße. Vielleicht sind die da sehr offen. Bei mir in der Straße ist ein Laden, der verkauft Fitness Supplements, so Proteinkram. Auch lange Heiz und CBD-Kram, also diese ganzen CBD-Gras. Ja, genau. Und der Headshot. Und Headshot ist ja... Okay. Nee, Headshot ist, wenn man sich, wenn man Gras raucht und dann in den Mund des anderen pustet. Das ist ein Headshot. Sag mal, dass du plötzlich in dieser Drogenwelt so zu Hause bist. Du bist ein neuer Mensch seit dieser Serie geworden. Du bist so cool. Ich will meinen alten Lappensteffern wieder haben. Lauchy. Lauchy mit Lauchface. Der ist tot. Lass los. Da frage ich mich auch. Alles an dem Laden sagt, wir dealen mit Gras. Das ist das einzige, was wir machen. Die haben sogar so ein Gras-Symbol vorne draufkleben. Die heißen Headshop. Die verkaufen ihre Tarnbusiness as Fitness Supplements. Ja. Die haben sogar so ein Grassymbol vorne drauf kleben und so. Die heißen Headshop, die verkaufen, ihr Tarnbusiness ist Fitness Supplements. Ja. Leute, alles daran sagt, wir verkaufen die Gras. Und da war auch neulich mal eine Party da drin, da hat man da Musik gehört, Rollladen waren so halb zu, dass man da noch reingucken konnte. Und die haben offensichtlich Gras geraucht und dann war mal Qualm aufgestiegen und so weiter. Und das war auch, denke ich mir auch, das ist auch nicht clever. Headshop. Es ist verrückt. Diese Läden, die geben sich auch keine Mühe. Ja, vielleicht ist also, vielleicht ist Kriminalität auch nicht so schwer oder halt nicht so gefährlich, wie man immer denkt. Vielleicht gibt es ja, weil ich meine, Kriminalität gibt es ja schon seit Tausenden und Hunderten von Jahren. Es hält sich lange dafür, dass es so gefährlich ist. Ja, es gibt ja wahrscheinlich Gebiete, die sich einfach etabliert haben, wo man einfach genau weiss, du verdienst halt nicht so mega viel, wenn du jetzt Menschenhandel machst oder so was, oder Drogenhandel oder Waffenhandel. Das ist halt super gefährlich, aber super rentabel. Aber so kleine Sachen vielleicht sind ja einfach okay rentabel und okay gefährlich. Drogenhandel ist wirklich super rentabel und super einfach auch, also wirklich zu einfach. Wir müssen mal überlegen, ob wir vielleicht nochmal Darknet da was verkaufen. Vielleicht müssen wir das machen. Ich habe jetzt überlegt, Bootsführerschein würde ich gerne machen. U-Boot und dann ganz viel Koks. Wie viel Koks passt in dieses U-Boot? Herr Tietze, gut, dass Sie fragen. Wir haben hier mal was vorbereitet. Ja, prospekt. Ich würde gerne einen Bootsführerschein machen und dann ein bisschen auf dem Rhein rumschippern. Mit so einem kleinen Bötchen. Und ich dachte mir, aber was sehr teuer ist, ist der Busführerschein. Und der ist auch sehr aufwendig. Bus-Bootsführerschein. Ah, Bus. Boots. Bus. Und aber Bootfahren ist doch ein bisschen wie Go-Kart. Du hast ein Gaspedal, du hast eine Bremse, vielleicht hast du keine Bremse. Ja, ein Anker. Du hast Dinge, aber du hast wenige Dinge. Du hast es nicht, du hast weniger Knöpfe als beim Auto, natürlich. Ja. Du hast einen Gashebel und einen Ruder. Aber willst du ein Motorboot? Ja, ein Motorbootsführerschein oder Segelbootführerschein. Kein Seebo. Du willst ja ein Seebo. Motorboot ist doch Seeboot für dich. Segelboot. Segelboot. Du willst ja nicht mit Mobo da durch den Rhein. Doch, Mobo oder Seebo. Beide am liebsten. Seebo und Mobo würde ich gerne machen. So, aber ich dachte, für beides kann man sich ja selber beibringen. Das ist ja kein Hexenwerk. Und da würde ich mir zum Beispiel gerne so einen Schein kaufen im Darknet. Einen schönen Bootsführerschein. Einen gefälschten Bootsschein. Ja, weil ich denke, das macht doch Sinn. Ein Autoführerschein macht keinen Sinn. Das ist ja wirklich etwas, was man auch gut lernen kann. Ja, vor allem wird man auf dem Wasser dann auch angehalten, rübergewunken, dann so fahren sie mal rechts ran. Die blitzen, wenn du zu schnell fährst, und dann musst du ranfahren, rechts ranfahren. Krass. Und dann musst du kurz ankern, vor Anker sein. Habe ich schon gelernt. Wow, Stefan. Nein, aber ich sage nur. Du hast schon ein YouTube-Video hinter dir. Ich sage nur, das ist wirklich, das ist so ein Schein, wo man sagt, oh ja, komm, sparen wir es uns. Nee, warum das nicht. Soll man ja nicht. Aber dann rein und runter, ist das dann so? Aufregend, spannend. Nee, weil du musst dann gegen die Strömung arbeiten oder du kommst halt nie wieder zurück. Du kannst in eine Richtung fahren und die andere kannst du halt, du bist halt nicht weitergetrieben. Du kannst, wenn du zu wenig PS hast, kannst du in eine Richtung dich nicht bewegen, dass du halt stehst, dass du halt so gerade. Heute fahre ich Boden, einfach immer auf der Stelle und dann hörst du auf irgendwann. Ja, so ein Laufband. Guckst halt in eine Richtung und bleibst stehen. Und du kannst es umdrehen, dann bist du halt weggetrieben. Das geht. Wow. Die beiden Dinge. Nicht schlecht. Ja, big fun. Big fun. Ja. Also ein U-Boot, kann man sich U-Boots kaufen? Ich glaube so Elon Musk oder so hat auch U-Boote. Ja, braucht man das, ist die Frage. Ist der nicht ein U-Boot? Im Rhein siehst du halt, glaube ich, nichts.
Ja, aber du hast ja so Nah und irgendwie so Infrarotsensoren und sowas. Bim, bop, bim, bim, bim, was, was kommt denn da an? Oh nein, Stefan mit einem anderen Boot. Stefan fährt nämlich rein, weil er keinen Bootsführerschein gemacht hat. Ja, aber ist das nicht klug, also auch zukunftsträchtig, wenn jetzt irgendwie die ganze Welt untergeht und der Meeresspiegel um 15 Meter steigt und du dann der einzige, macht's gut, ihr Trottel, auf deinem Boot wegfährst? Hausboot, Hausboot, finde ich gut. Ja, Harbo, kannst du natürlich auch machen, wenn du dich da auf... Ich meine, im Grunde ist jedes Haus ein Boot. Nee. Und jedes Boot ein Haus. Da würden, glaube ich, viele Flutopfer würden jetzt sagen, mein Haus war kein Harbo. Ja gut, aber ich meine, du musst halt nur einen Stock höher ziehen und dann halt den Keller aufgeben. Das ist halt der Keller voller Wasser und das Erdgeschoss wird zum Keller. Wie kommst du denn raus? Über das Erdgeschoss. Ach stimmt, das ist ein Problem, weil wenn das Wasser nur um drei Meter steigt, verlierst du zwei Stockwerke, Keller und Erdgeschoss. Du verlierst Keller, Erdgeschoss und jeglichen Weg raus und jegliche Existenz, weil die Stadt ist ja auch weg. Die meisten Dinge, machen wir uns das vor, die meisten Dinge passieren im Erdgeschoss. So heißt auch meine Geografie. Da sagst du was. Die meisten Dinge passieren im Erdgeschoss. Hast du jetzt was gesagt? Alle Läden, Elbgeschoss, dein Supermarkt, Elbgeschoss, dein Shady-Supermarkt, Elbgeschoss. Und dann vor allem, wenn da das Wasser steigt, dann kommt das ganze Geld so aus dem Hinterraum rausgeschwommen. Nein, das Geld! Aber es ist super praktisch, für jegliche Formen der Apokalypse Sonnenladen in der Nähe zu haben. So eine Geldwäsche, wir haben Dinge, die sich ewig halten, Mark, ist perfekt. Das ist genau das, was du brauchst. Und am Ende sind die die einzigen, die die Apokalypse überleben, einfach weil sie dann irgendwie ihre Süssauersauce getrunken haben, die ganze Polokausen. Ja, weil die Geld wie Scheiße haben, die Drogenhandel. Ja. Und weil die halt sehr viel Wasser und Konserven haben. Macht schon Sinn. Ja, diese ganzen, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ich kaufe, ich habe, dieser Laden sieht auch so aus, als würden die keine Euro nehmen. Also der hat so ein, der hat so ein, so eine Fremdartigkeit, der wirkt wie eine Filmkulisse. Also ich weiß nicht, es hat einfach so ein Gefühl. Hast du mal die Hand reingehalten? Noch nicht, ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht sind es auch nur, ich weiß nicht. So ein 2D-Projektion.
Es ist so ganz merkwürdig, irgendwie, also wenn dann irgendwie so, dann passiert da was, irgendwie große Schießereien, dann passen dann Interviews und dann sagt, oft gibt es ja dann so dieses, nee, ich hätte mir nie mit gerechnet, der war ganz normal. Ich würde sagen, nee, ich habe sofort mit gerechnet. Der war's, ja klar, seit der ersten Sekunde habe ich gesagt, da ist was los. Also ich meine, wenn man an Polizeirufen denkt, denkt man ja immer an Notruf. Ich bin in akuter Gefahr, ich brauche Hilfe. Aber kann man die Polizei auch mal anrufen, so im Sinne von, ich glaube, da finden Verbrechen statt. Genau, ich habe ja schon mal die Polizei anrufen müssen, weil ich mein Auto nicht gefunden habe. Gut, aber das ist auch eine Form von Notruf. Du brauchst Hilfe oder Hilfe. Du rufst mich nicht bei der 1-0 an, du rufst bei der Kölner Nummer an. Okay, aber du brauchst Hilfe. Du willst, dass die helfen. Aber kann man die Polizei auch... Nee, aber nee, du warst hilflos, zappelnd lagst du auf dem Rücken. Und Papa Staat musste wieder kommen, um dir auf die Beine zu helfen. Und was hast du zurückgegeben? Papa Staat hat mich mich aber auch umgeworfen, weil die mein Auto geklaut haben, die mein Auto haben abgeschleppt. Jetzt kannst du es wieder drehen und wenden, wie du willst. Ja, die haben mich, wenn ich in diesem hilflos zappelnden Metapher die Schildkröte bin, die auf dem Panzer gefallen ist, hat Papa Starr mich umgedreht. Gut. Ja, das habe ich ja nur. Da haben wir jetzt eine 360 gemacht. Ja. Gut. Aber kann man da mal so anrufen und sagen so, ich glaube, die waschen da Geld? Ja. Oder sagen die, ja, wow, da sind wir jetzt nicht drauf gekommen, tschüss. Oder machst du dich da illegal, weil du den Finger, weil du den gegen den Finger auf anderen zeigen Paragrafen verstößt. Wenn du mit einem Finger auf andere zeigst, zeigen vier auf dich zurück Paragrafraf. Drei. Ja, kommt darauf an, welche Hände man hat. Wenn man die normalen Hände hat, drei. Es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, wie? Ja. Der Daumen zeigt aber auch meistens weg. Das stimmt. Ich habe mal beobachtet, wie im Hinterhof von meiner Wohnung nachts zwei Autos ihre Nummernschilder getauscht haben. Ja. Wo ich auch dachte, das ist wahrscheinlich Teil einer kriminellen Handlung. Auto geklaut oder Fluchtwagen, keine Ahnung. Fragen wir mal so, wir können es mal falsifizieren. Denken wir uns eine Situation aus, wo die das gemacht haben, die Sinn macht in einem legalen Rahmen. Naja, klassischer Auffahrunfall, man stösst zusammen mit einem anderen, sagt, oh, nichts passiert, kein Kratzer, shake hands, man fährt nach Hause. Abends schaut man mal auf sein Nummernschild und merkt, beim Auffahrunfall sind die Nummernschilder ausgetauscht worden. Ach Gottchen! Du grüne Neune, was jetzt? Beziehungsweise jetzt achte. Zum Glück haben wir die Nummern ausgetauscht, aber es ist schon spät. Dann fahren wir die Nummern irgendwo. Kann ich noch anrufen? Wann ist die Nummern schild Austausch Cut-off-Time? Kann man um neun Uhr noch anrufen? Weiß ich nicht. Aber dann fahren wir doch jetzt, treffen uns lieber irgendwo, wo wir niemanden stören. In dem dunklen Hinterhof zum Beispiel.
Nicht, dass jemand noch denkt, oh, die machen was Illegales.
Genau, damit niemand jetzt Angst hat.
Also trefft man sich in dem Hinterhof und tauscht die Nummer natürlich wieder aus.
Ah, Shake Hands, dumm gelaufen.
Und wir sind beim kurzen Nachdenken schon auf eine Situation gekommen, die zeigt, also wahrscheinlich ist es Quatsch. Wenn ich Dussel da jetzt die Polizei gerufen hätte und die kommen da irgendwie mit Hubschrauber und Einsatzkräften, dann wäre ich der dumme Trottel. Ja, neulich hat ein Kollege, da habe ich das gleiche gedacht, der hat nämlich einen Kinderwagen gesehen ohne Kind drin. Ein Mann fährt einen Kinderwagen ohne Kind. Es tut mir leid, aber das ist, ich dachte kurz, warum rufst du die Polizei nicht?
Warum nicht?
Ist das ein Vater, der sich vorbereitet oder man geht mit einer Fehlgeburt um oder sowas? Ja, aber man kann trotzdem mal, ich würde einfach anrufen, kurzer, hey, Stefan hier, kurzer Heads up, wenn ein Kind fehlt. Ja, es war also und es war auf dem Friedhof.
Es war so ein grosses Hühnchen.
Also so der Freiraum war ungefähr so
diese zwei Hühnchen übereinander.
Gut, danke.
Es war auf dem Friedhof, muss man dabei sagen.
Auf dem grossen Friedhof in Köln, der Hauptfriedhof.
Da war eine Schaufel dabei.
War eine Schaufel dabei, er war ganz dreckig,
blutig beschmiert und das Kind hat gefehlt. Wenn ein Kind fehlt in Grossraum Köln. Ich habe einen Mann gesehen, mit einem Kinderwagen ohne Kind. Wenn es fehlt und ihr sucht ein Kind oder so, ruf mich doch mal an, ich kann euch den Mann erklären. Ich sage, das müsst ihr ja gar nichts wissen. Nur Stefan war mein Name, easy. Ja, aber tatsächlich, wo ich mittlerweile sensibilisiert wurde, sind entführte Kinder, weil zum Beispiel auch bei dem Film Room oder so oder auch bei, ich glaube bei Natascha Kampusch war es auch so, dass die ja manchmal dass sie manchmal rausgehen mit ihren Kindern und die Kinder dann so versuchen, nach Hilfe zu rufen, aber eher nicht können, wenn sie ja mit ihrem Kidnapper unterwegs sind und dann auf subtile Art und deswegen immer, wenn ich jemanden Kind sehe. Ja, Problem ist nur, Kinder sind denkbar weird, also denkbar sind so seltsam wie Kinder. Ja, aber wenn sie ein Schild hochhalten mit Hilfe, ich wurde entführt, da achte ich jetzt drauf, ob sie ein Schild hochhalten mit Hilfe, ich wurde entführt. Hilfe, das ist nicht mein Vater neben mir. Und ich versuche immer zu gucken, bist du entführt? Man kann ja auch random Kinder fragen, wurdest du entführt? Würde ein Kind das entführt, würde sagen, ja. Und der Entführer so, verdammt nochmal, ist ja gut. Ja, genau. Ich achte wirklich immer darauf, wie Kinder, gibt dieses Kind mir gerade
Zeichen, dass es
gerettet werden will.
Ich glaube, am Ende dieser
Entscheidung, die du gerade triffst,
landest du im Klass, weil du die Kinder anguckst. Es ist viel zu lange. Ich habe das Kind nicht entführt, ich wollte es nur vom Entführer wieder zurückbringen. Mein Gott, nichts kann man hier machen. Sie haben 15 Eltern die Kinder entrissen. Ja, ich wollte es wieder zurückbringen zu den ursprünglichen Eltern. Ich habe diesen Kinderwagen gesehen ohne Kind und dachte mir, das Kind muss zurück. Kann man einfach mal, ich weiß nicht, weil irgendwie die Polizei fragt ja manchmal nach Hilfe, so sorry, wir packen es nicht, wir kriegen es nicht hin, hat jemand diesen Typen gesehen, wir finden ihn nicht. Ja, so, sorry, peinlich, wir finden ihn nicht, habt ihr den gesehen, nee, gut, dann sorry, dann auch egal. So, kann man da nicht mal proaktiv sagen, ich habe hier was beobachtet, ich habe was gesehen. Wie abhängig ist die Polizei von solchen, von Zivilcourage auf eine Art? Oder halt Snitchen, das kommt halt darauf an, wie es Pätze, weil ich habe Angst, was Pätze vielleicht zu werden am Telefon von der Polizei. Pätze, Pätze, okay.
Eigentlich will man ja eigentlich, also so wenn man sich jetzt so die Sopranos anschaut, dann denkt man sich, die schlagen jetzt da jemand in einem Hinterhof zusammen und dann ruft jemand die Polizei, dann will man nicht der sein, sondern sich denkt, du deppst so. Ich meine, das bringt nichts. Ich weiss es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht rufe ich die Polizei an und sage ihnen, ja, hier ist definitiv Geldwäsche oder ich nehme den Laden selber hoch. Was kann man machen, um die hochzunehmen? Also kann man da einfach denen alles wegkaufen und dann kriegen die Probleme, aber die haben keine Nachversorgung. Du kennst nicht genau, wann der Begriff organisierte Kriminalität zum Tragen kommt, aber die haben einen Laden. Die haben sich die Mühe gemacht, diesen Laden, dieses, dieses, du wohnst ja auch in einer guten Zentralen Lage in Köln, das heißt die zahlen eine gewisse Miete für diesen Laden. Entscheidungen wurden getroffen, Vorkehrungen wurden getroffen, ein Logo wurde entworfen. Man hat sich für eine Klingel entschieden. Konserven wurden gekauft, ein Konzept wurde sich überlegt. Und dann gehst du zu diesem Gangsterboss. Ganz kurz für diesen Laden. Wir haben jetzt hier das grüne Design und das gelbe Design. Ich finde, das grüne spricht ein bisschen mehr. Irgendwas, mir ist scheißegal. Ich dachte, wir gehen so ein bisschen auf so einen Wellness-Trip, weil es ja relativ momentan ganz gut ankommt. Mir ist das scheißegal. Wir müssen den Laden einfach aufmachen. Wir brauchen eine Entscheidung, grün oder gelb. Gelb. Wirklich gelb. Ich dachte, mit dem grün geht es ein bisschen. Oh mein Gott, dann halt grün. Okay, gut, okay, dann grün. Wunderbar. Aber so eine Entscheidung wurden fällt. Entscheidungen wurden gefällt. Ja, okay. Und deswegen meine ich nur, es ist vielleicht organisierte Kriminalität und ich würde da nicht einfach reingehen und sagen, ich habe sie festgenommen. Sie sind verhaftet. Sie sind verhaftet. Oder mal gucken, wie er reagiert. Oh nein! Oh nein! Jetzt habe ich dich aber. Jetzt habe ich dich aber. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was man da macht. Wie kann ich den jetzt so Batman-mäßig selber hochnehmen? Halt erst mal die Füsse still. Einen Satz, den ich liebe. Du kennst meine Füsse, Stefan. Ich liebe es, wenn es zu mir gesagt wird, weil es bedeutet nichts tun, ich liebe es, wenn man es zu anderen sagt, weil es immer klingt wie so ein Movie-Zitat, es ist aber auch kein abgenuttes Zitat im Deutschen, es ist nicht so abgegriffen, aber halt mal die Füsse still. Aber auf der anderen Seite, vielleicht ist es nur ein Laden, der halt irgendwie denkt, okay, wenn wir jetzt unser ganzes Geld ausgeben für Tiefkühlwaren, dann werden die schlecht und wir können uns gerade diese Tiefkühl... Vielleicht ist es ein normaler Laden, der jetzt aber einfach nur Imageprobleme hat, weil alle davon ausgehen, dass er Geldwäsche hat. Mit einem suspekten Konzept einfach. Und ist nicht eigentlich auch... Wie hier Bullet Shop oder Waffenshop auch per se shady wirkt, obwohl es ja einfach ein Waffenfeld sein kann. Aber ist denn nicht eigentlich Geldwäsche eine Möglichkeit für Kriminelle, aus der Kriminalität rauszukommen? Ich glaube, es gibt sogar irgendeine Firma, die ursprünglich als Geldwäsche gestartet ist, aber dann so lukrativ
war, dass die Gangster irgendwann
aufgehört haben, ihr Gangsterzeug zu machen,
sondern einfach angefangen haben, legal über diese
Firma Geld zu verdienen. Irgendeine Kette.
Wenn die den Quatsch verkaufen, wie dein Laden,
dann, glaube ich, ist es kein Ausstieg.
Nee, die bräuchte die...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn man da genug einkauft, vielleicht kriegt man die dann weg. Man kann die Kriminalität auf zwei Arten bekämpfen. Einmal natürlich kann man sie verhaften und bestrafen, oder man setzt an und versucht sie auf den rechten Pfad zurückzubringen. Geht doch mal rein und leg dir mal einfach so einen Fuffi auf den Tisch. Ja, einfach mal so einen Geldkopf. Sag, ich will nichts kaufen, bitteschön. Und dann kriegst du bestimmt, entweder kriegst du so ein Pechchen Koks zugesteckt, oder aber die nehmen es an und freuen sich. Ich glaube, ich sammle Beweise in letzter Zeit. Ich gucke mal, wer da so reingeht und rausgeht. Gut, also nach dem Tüftel-Florentin beginnt jetzt auch noch Detective-Florentin, der anfängt sich irgendwie so eine Spiegelreflex zu kaufen. Ich nehme die Gerechtigkeit in meine eigene Hand, Florentin. Ich will mal in der Zeitung stehen, als engagierter Bürger nimmt Kriminellen Ring hoch. Es sind immer die Ersten, aber die Verdächtigen in den Dokus von Netflix. Die sind Leute, die die Kamera im Hals senken haben und die Dinge in die eigene Hand nehmen und immer besonders die Ersten am Tatort sind. Ich fotografiere halt Tatorte als Hobby. Welcher Mensch hat so ein Hobby? Bitte fotografiere nicht Kinder, weil du denk du denkst, die sind entführt worden, nicht die ganze Zeit. Naja, damit man es abgleichen kann, falls die... Aber solche Leute sind immer die Ersten, die war Maddie McKay, aber auch der erste Typ, der verdächtigt wurde, bis zum Ende auch, dessen Leben die ruiniert haben, war der Typ, der die ganze Zeit seine Hilfe angeboten hat, weil er der einzige, der die Sprache gesprochen hat. Ich sage nur, mach genau, mach weniger Fotos von Kindern. Okay, gut, du hast mich überzeugt. Vielen Dank an Christoph für das fantastische Intro. Ich bin sehr krank, ich fall gerade so ein bisschen auseinander. Ja, kein Problem, dann geh lieber mal, gehst du jetzt noch essen heute? Ich gehe heute nicht mehr essen, heute gehe ich einfach noch raus. Nee, heute gönn dir mal einen schönen Deckenabend, zwei, drei Decken auch einfach einfach drauf. Oh, finde ich so schlecht. Weißt du, was ein schöner Moment ist? Wenn man seine Bettdecke aus dem Bett auf die Couch holt. Oh! Herrlich. Sag bei mir immer, oh, da ist jemand aber krank. Oder einfach sehr, sehr kuschelig. Und wir wünschen euch natürlich jetzt auch einen kuscheligen Tagabend. Eine kuschelige Woche. Oh, eine kuschelige Woche. Macht's gut, wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Und trink mal eine Tasse Tee mit zwei Händen, sofort gemütlich, sofort cozy.
Macht's gut, wir heben ab leise, tschüss.